hi YouTube my name is Chevy that the
pleasure of being asked this difficult
question don't get it my best shot my
feeling is if there's one thing that
could say ask making the world a better
place e 2008 is to be able to ask for
political leaders to stand up to the
challenges that they have and the
conflicts that are costing in the lives
around the world not only in our part of
the region in our world and the least
tundra but in Asia and Latin America are
the parts of the world I think the world
needs more people like presidents adapt
who was able to stand up to the
responsibility take up the challenge and
be able to find sustainable just and
peaceful solutions that have a human
race and it's sort of bottom line and
unless people stand up to that
responsibility and sadly and I've given
the state of the world I think we will
go into ish a circle which will continue
and maybe even get worse so if there's
one thing that I hope 2008 or bring is
to provide visual encourage stand up and
take that sort of responsibility work
together as a team
to make this world a better place